[Musique]
le 17 février 2014 j'ai tenu entre mes
mains le Graal de beaucoup de sportifs
l'équipe suisse que j'entraînais que je
manageais est devenu ce jour-là
championne olympique de Bob à deux à
Sotchi
championne olympique une médaille d'or
quelle émotion quand l'équipe passe la
ligne d'arrivée et que le rêve devient
réalité
26 ans après mes débuts dans ce sport 26
ans de doutes d'échecs mais aussi de
joie de victoire de rencontre de partage
d'expérience
26 ans
c'est long quand je repense à ma
première descente d'ailleurs on me
demande souvent comment on commence le
bobsleigh comment un jour on a cette
idée folle de s'asseoir dans une espèce
de baignoire géante pour dévaler des
toboggans classés à 150 km heure
ma famille est une famille de sportif
mon père est un champion il a participé
deux fois aux Jeux olympiques en 1956 à
Melbourne et 1960 à Rome au lancer du
disque
ma première piscine c'est la rivière du
3000 mètres stiple sur le stade
d'athlétisme sur lequel il s'entraîne
j'ai donc littéralement toujours baigné
dans cette atmosphère de sport
et mon père avait un rituel quotidien
lire le journal L'Équipe
et dès que j'ai su lire et bien
j'attends des fébrilement qu'il ait fini
de le lire ou qu'il s'endorme lors de sa
sieste pour lui prendre son journal
écouter regardez lire le récit des
Champions et des événements sportifs
internationaux
toute mon adolescence a été baignée par
ça le Tour de France mais
il nous finions le football le coup
franc magique de Platini en novembre
1981 qui envoie la France au Mondial en
Espagne en 1982 qui nous a donné
beaucoup de joie mais qui a aussi donné
des sueurs froides au collégien et
lycéens quand ils ont retrouvé ce coup
franc lors d'un exercice de
mathématiques avec la question suivante
en vous servant de formule
trigonométriques calculer la vitesse du
ballon
102 km heure pour ceux qui se posent la
question
expérience vécue
le tennis la rivalité Borg McEnroe
Yannick Noah qui gagne en 1983 le
dernier Grand Chelem pour les Français à
Roland-Garros et bien sûr la cléisme
guide rue champion olympique en 1976
Pierre Quinon en 1984
je fais du sport je ne fais pas que le
lire je pratique le ski alpin mais je
garde de mon père cette pratique
quotidienne de lire l'équipe et un jour
de septembre 1988 je tombe sur un petit
article vous êtes grand costaud et fort
vous pourrez vite vous voulez
représenter la France aux Jeux
Olympiques venez essayer le bobsleigh
rendez-vous le samedi 10 septembre à
Voiron pour des tests physiques
il faut savoir qu'à cette époque
l'équipe de France de bobsleigh n'existe
pas
on a vu Rasta Rockett qui retrace
l'aventure de l'équipe jamaicaine de
bobsleigh en 1988 à Calgary lors de
cette édition il n'y a pas de Français
qui pratique ce sport mais quatre ans
plus tard en 1992 les jeux ont lieu à
Albertville en France et le Comité
olympique français veut que dans toutes
les disciplines la France soit
représentée d'où cette opération de
recrutement je n'ai rien à faire ce
samedi là de particulier j'habite à côté
de Voiron je m'y rends on me fait courir
on me fait soulever des poids on me fait
pousser des bobs à roulettes et
finalement je suis dans les 20 meilleurs
à qui on propose un mois plus tard de
tester pour de vrai une descente en
bobsleigh et c'est comme ça que je me
retrouve en Autriche à Eagles sur la
piste des Jeux olympiques de 1976 aux
manettes d'un bobsleigh avec des
consignes très simples
tu as une manette dans la main gauche tu
tires à gauche ton Bob il va à gauche tu
as une manette dans la main droite tu
tires à droite ton Bob il va à droite
c'était ma première descente des
milliers d'autres suivront
des milliers d'autres ou chaque hiver
pratiquement chaque jour j'ai fait un
pas de côté
ou plutôt un saut de côté les 10
premières années c'était pour monter
dans mon Bob entre la phase de pousser
et la face de pilotage durant les 20
années suivantes c'était pour enseigner
au bobber que j'entraînais comment
réaliser ce geste pour qu'il devienne
automatique et parfait et qu'il
participe à la teinte de notre objectif
parce que pendant ces 30 ans j'ai
toujours eu en tête cet objectif d'un
titre olympique
un titre ambitieux certes mais aussi
tellement motivant qui vous permet de
dépasser vos limites physiques qui vous
fait oublier les courbatures les
douleurs articulaires le goût du sang
dans la bouche quand votre séance est
tellement intense que vos muscles sont
gorgés d'acide lactique qui vous fait
dépasser également vous limite mentale
qui vous fait entraîner votre capacité
de résilience quand les mauvais
résultats s'enchaînent ou qu'en d'une
blessure vous met sur le côté pendant
des semaines des mois voire toute une
saison qui vous apprend aussi à gérer le
stress quand l'échéance approche quant
de bobber anonyme pendant des années
vous vous retrouvez sous la loupe
olympique qui grossit 10 fois 100 fois
toutes les actions que vous faites
et pour arriver à gérer tout ça on fait
ce qu'on appelle un BPO un business plan
olympique comme peuvent le faire des
entreprises on définit des objectifs
annuels
trimestrielle mensuel ont défini les
actions qu'on va mettre en place pour
qu'au final notre plan d'action amène
cette médaille autour du cou en
progressant petit à petit en faisant
progresser toutes les composantes de la
réussite mais également en faisant de
temps en temps des pas de côté
pour aller voir ce que font les autres
comment ils progresse quels sont leurs
méthodes quelles sont leurs outils non
pas pour copier bêtement tout ce qu'ils
font mais pour s'en imprégner s'en
inspirer et les adapter à notre propre
pratique en gardant nos valeurs nos
qualités et notre moi profond
c'est ça qui nous permet de progresser
et qui nous permet dans notre cercle de
confiance d'aller chercher les limites
d'aller au bord parce que dans ce cercle
on sait qu'il ne peut rien nous arriver
et parfois on essaye d'en sortir un
petit peu
et un peu plus
mais pas trop loin parce qu'il faut qu'à
tout moment on puisse revenir à
l'intérieur de ce cercle on n'a aucun
doute
pour pouvoir revenir à quelque chose qui
nous plaît qui est stable quand on a des
échecs parce que des échecs on en aura
lors des Jeux de 1992 je suis
sélectionné 4 ans après mes débuts en
bobsleigh faire les Jeux Olympiques pour
un sportif c'est exceptionnel faire les
Jeux Olympiques dans son propre prix
c'est encore plus rare la cérémonie
d'ouverture le défilé rentré en tant que
dernière délégation dans ce stade Michel
Platini qui allume la flamme
les entraînements la compétition la
ferveur populaire en France le dernier
entraînement avec la sélection
franco-française pour décider qui
participera à ces jeux
et finalement je suis remplaçant
je fais tout lors de ces Jeux Olympiques
sauf la compétition la déception est
immense
mais deux ans plus tard les prochains
jeux arrivent pourquoi deux ans et non
pas 4 ans parce qu'à cette époque le
comité olympique a décidé de décaler les
Jeux d'hiver et Jeux d'été
après 92 Albertville on aura 94 il la
meurt je me remets en place arrive 94 et
pour quelques points dans un classement
international je ne participe pas non
plus à ces jeux
résilience quand tu nous tiens
je continue quand même le bob mais comme
le dit Einstein la folie c'est de faire
toujours la même chose en espérant des
résultats différents je change de
matériel je change d'équipier je change
d'entraîneur et ça fonctionne en février
95 à Winterberg en Allemagne avec mon
équipier nous décrochons une médaille de
bronze au championnats du monde la
première dans cette discipline et dans
l'histoire de ce sport pour la France
la machine est relancée dans trois ans
les Jeux Olympiques à Nagano se
profilent février 1996 Calgary
championnat du monde à l'avant du Bob
j'ai le numéro 3 qui montre que l'année
d'avant je suis médaillé et là je finis
20 23e
23e si jamais facile de gagner le
médaille mais entre 3e et 23e 8e 10e 12e
et je me pose des questions qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé on s'est pourtant bien
entraîné on n'a pas tout changé comment
se fait-il qu'on était troisième et un
an et 23e aujourd'hui j'essaye de
repenser à cette semaine à Winterberg où
on a gagné la médaille et je me rends
compte d'une chose primordiale d'un
oubli
j'ai oublié d'analyser mon succès
je n'ai pas fait de feedback de cette
semaine ou tout a fonctionné parce que
souvent quand on investit son temps son
argent s'assure sa vie de famille dans
un objectif et qu'on réussit il est
facile de se dire c'est normal qu'on
réussisse on a tellement travaillé
et on peut éviter on ne peut ne pas
arriver à dissocier l'émotion de la
réflexion
alors qu'en faisant un pas de côté en
prenant du recul de la hauteur on va
pouvoir analyser frottement et avec
méthode ce qui a fonctionné avec trois
points essentiels le premier c'est
est-ce que cette fois là
il y a eu des différences dans ce qu'on
a fait pour se rendre compte du process
consciemment qu'on a mis en place
la deuxième question c'est est-ce qu'on
a utilisé de nouvelles compétences
pour se rendre compte de sa propre
amélioration et enfin avec la réponse à
ces deux questions comment on peut
améliorer
notre processus du succès innover pour
toujours se motiver et ces trois
questions sont primordiales pour
maximiser vos chances de réussite elles
entraîneront une dernière petite
question et si et si ce jour-là dans la
compétition il avait neigé est-ce que
j'avais tout le matériel pour performer
et si lors de ce rendez-vous commercial
mon client m'avait posé telle question
ou demander tel document est-ce que
j'étais apte à lui répondre à lui
apporter ce qu'il demandait pour prévoir
ce qui aurait pu se passer et que vous
n'aviez pas prévu pour vous préparer
sans être forcément obligé de passer par
l'échec pour apprendre
améliorer continuellement votre plan
d'action pour le partager avec votre
équipe parce que vous travaillerez
toujours en équipe que vous soyez dans
un sport individuel ou dans une
entreprise individuelle vous aurez
toujours autour de vous une équipe ça
peut être un préparateur mental physique
un diététicien ça peut être vos clients
vos fournisseurs vos partenaires vous
travaillerez en équipe
avec des différences culturelles des
différences d'éducation des différences
d'opinions des différences de croyances
servez-vous de ces différences pour en
faire une force partagez vos expériences
ne restez pas assis sur votre chaise
mais asseyez-vous à la place de vos
collaborateurs asseyez-vous à la place
des gens de votre équipe pour voir
comment ils pensent comment il
fonctionne pour petit à petit agrandir
la base de votre pyramide du succès et
plus la base de cette pyramide sera
grande est stable et moins vous prendrez
de risques en ajoutant une pierre à son
sommet pour vous rapprocher de votre
objectif final
car tous ces pattes côté finalement
qu'il soit technique comme monté dans un
bobsleigh qu'il soit du type management
logistique structurel et bien il vous
feront progresser leurs effets vont
s'additionner vont se multiplier même
dans un seul et unique but
faire en sorte que quand votre 17
février 2014 sera là vous soyez prêts et
vous ne passiez pas à côté de ce moment
merci
[Applaudissements]